[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cowboys have a bye week tim calishaw
never does dallas morning news columnist
and starve around the horn and he joins
us on the program wow we got good things
to talk about don't we oh my this is
unusual this is unusual for us last time
morale was this high in dallas was
oh
uh well 2016 the 11-game winning streak
dak and zeke as rookies
the sky was the limit
uh they had found their future
and here we are five years later
waiting for this team to capitalize on
dak and zeke being here they kind of got
sideways for a few years and and didn't
really take advantage of it but the
excitement around that team
this year
while dak and zeke are obviously still
here the digs that you already mentioned
um
you know cd lamb the younger players are
what make people think even randy
gregory to an extent make people think
wow there are some different stars here
and maybe this will be different
what are your concerns
well it starts with the head coach yes
it's kind of unfair
you know and i've been maybe overly
harsh on him here and some of the things
people got on him for yesterday didn't
really bother me i it made sense to kick
the field goal
that he missed zeroline missed
uh you know he went for it early fourth
and one that their own what 35.
that's unconventional but we've been
screaming for coaches to pay attention
to these analytics and say if you've got
a good offense and they have a great one
you can make a yard you shouldn't punt
the ball away
and they didn't make the yard and so so
it didn't look good and it that kind of
energized the patriots what they score
in three plays after that uh josh
mcdaniels called his best three plays he
had
and they're running tricks and next
thing they're in the end zone
and you know that kind of kept him
afloat for the day
but
mccarthy is a concern i think
and uh
you know the defense is still
although they're making the
interceptions and some of the plays
and yesterday they're not playing
against a great offense they still give
up stuff i mean look at the look at the
play they gave up to almost lose the
game so you gotta you gotta still be a
little leery of that
yeah i'm with you with uh mccarthy i
didn't think they should have gone for
it on the fourth down in their own
territory i would have gone for the
fourth down when they needed a yard late
in the game he calls a timeout that
helped the patriots
yeah
his misunderstanding of the clock
continues to baffle all of us you call a
timeout if you're gonna go for it yeah
he called a timeout and kicked the field
goal yeah so then you're giving the team
time
now the patriots didn't happen to do
anything with it but
the the clock management has been an
ongoing thing the thing about the fourth
and one early that you can say look you
don't need to take that risk
you're a much better team than new
england don't give them the ball at your
own 34. yep and i just think they're a
little cocky and they think we're gonna
drive down here and score a touchdown
and and it bit him
yeah um in that offensive line there
were holes that were unbelievable that's
why i thought you can get a yard against
this new england defense that and and
keep the clock going it just surprised
yeah
yeah
uh
they had run zeke on third and one and
look it looks like zeke's gonna get it
and somebody comes in and blasts him and
he's got the ball in his back arm uh
they made a little bit you know they
outgained the patriots by more than 230
yards that was a weird game to watch to
say how did they not have this game put
away and then obviously they almost lost
it
uh they came in the penalties too
penalties uh yeah it was a sloppy game
they got a bye week coming up i'm sure
the players are thinking about that
let's get an easy win over the patriots
and go have a few days off
and so they didn't play their best
but they did they did cd lamb was there
when they needed him and uh
and so they're five and one
you start to look at that division and
look at it not long term but at least in
the next three years you know the giants
are going to be in a rebuild they're
going to need a new quarterback uh maybe
a new head coach on gm saquon barkley
won't be there uh the eagles are gonna
be in a rebuild we're not sure about the
washington football team on and off the
field i mean this is a great position a
great window for the next three years
you would think for the cowboys
i was thinking about that this morning
uh
they could be going against three
different quarterbacks next year as
early as next year the eagles right now
don't they have they have like three
picks in the top ten yeah and so if
they're if they're not in full belief
that hurts is the answer they're going
to use one of those on a quarterback you
would think
danny dimes
i don't know he looks okay i don't know
if
i don't know if i'm ready to pull the
plug on him but that's a mess of a team
in new york and washington you're right
they don't have their quarterback they
know that
but they knew that when they brought in
uh
you know
fits magic so it's it's
they're going to win the debate
calgary's going to win the division by
five games or six and because they got
four more games against those teams
you know they got a shot at
you know it used to be you play for the
top two seeds now now there's only one
that gets the bye
and you're playing with arizona team
dallas plays at home
january 2nd
and you compete with the rams
you compete with the bucks the team the
cowboys lost to that could still hurt
them but they're they're in that
competition
when did you realize or when did the
cowboys realize they had something
special in trayvon dinks
i think they knew last year i don't
think they envisioned
anything like this i think he was just
really
sound really solid right away like i
could start in this league i can play
what do you need me to do i'll be your
best quarterback quarterback
and uh
and man he just started making plays
this year and i thought it was funny
that he got beat for the touchdown you
know we've written all these things and
said these things about everson walls
in his first two years he had 11
interceptions that's the most in the
last 40 years
and then he had seven in a strike season
there were only um
whatever there were 12 games
um maybe nine games the very that was
the short strikes he's 1982.
um
and but everson got beat a lot emerson
took a lot of chances diggs hasn't been
beaten that often but i thought okay
this guy really is everest waltz he just
ran one back for a touchdown he just
gave up
this this this does remind me of 40
years ago
yeah i remember everson walls would
gamble and then he would make a big play
yeah
and and they don't throw in your
direction if you're darrell rivas if
they think you're going to gamble and
they can take advantage of that they'll
continue to throw in your direction
there's a reason walls is the only
player who's led the
interceptions three times because they
kept throwing that
oh
morale is high look at you yes yeah
mavs mavs hawks thursday yeah
luca and trey here we go yeah mvp
favorites
no
oh okay well that's what people said
that's what i was told that was
misinformed how about you texas longhor
oh no
my alma mater
you're doing a zoom call and those
listening on radio don't realize that
whatever the picture is behind you gives
you devil's horns
and you should probably change that
picture okay so
go over here you you look like you have
you're the devil
and and i know better like the old you
was the devil before i came on the
gentleman kept going slide a little
little more right there
so the big german my director
did this he set you up
yes yeah you have well disapproved
that's the way half your audience sees
the cowboys in that light
fans love them half of them think this
is
hellacious that the cowboys are good
again and they're going to be obnoxious
again how's jerry jones been is jerry
even more confident cocky
he
he's been almost a little low-key for
him
well definitely low key for him uh
yeah i mean i think but i think that
means he thinks that they're pretty good
and he's not really
he's kind of just got his fingers
crossed but
things have looked like they'd be good
in the recent past and injuries or
something i've derailed this team
uh the catch in green bay whatever
there's something that has gotten in his
way and and i think he's starting to
feel like hey maybe that 25-year nfc
championship
game drought maybe they could maybe they
could end that this year have you been
in his suite before
i have not i have uh
used to go to his office many times at
valley ranch but i have not been in that
suite i i don't believe i have a
standing invitation to go in there
what if you went in to clean his glasses
yes if i if i would offer to do that
i asked him about going for a ride on
the boat one time i called it the boat i
think he was offended i called him the
boat
given that it looks like uh you know
logan roy in succession you know
something like that
200 250 feet long i think um
and he said something about if i want to
work on the boat i might get the
opportunity yeah
we'll be there yeah great to talk to you
again tim are you on around the whole
tonight
i'm on today and tomorrow that there's
got to be wind number 502
has to be around the corner
500 gets you into the hall of fame
doesn't it 500 does and i think i've
been in kind of a malaise since then i
haven't really
put it together i lost last week to
meena times in a showdown i lost to
sarah spain i just i'm not i'm not
closing i'm not finishing i'm the
dodgers all of a sudden
i'm doing the wrong things at the end of
the game all of a sudden
is anybody gonna catch woody page on
around the horn well he's got over 600
i would have to stay on for seven more
years
that's
not in my planet i'm sure that's not
enough
yeah uh woody is sort of jerry rice
you're larry fitzgerald
i'll take that i'll be i i'm
friends with larry i'll i'll take that
i'll i'll be the guy who grinds away the
guy who hands the ball to the ref
and as he after he scores a touchdown
just doing my job of course you are
thank you tim always great to catch up
with you of course you are
change the background there change your
horns
it's not even hookum horns
it isn't
thank you tim that's tim callashaw
dallas morning news and of course around
the horn contributor